so uh hello everyone now today i'm going
to be talking about why you should
consider webassembly in your next
frontend project um
so my name is hogan silvenogl i work
with machine learning and ai at miles
and before we dive into webassembly i'm
just going to give you some more
background information about
me so my background is
in human machine interfaces for process
automation
and robotics i have a master's degree in
electrical engineering and also master's
degree in behavioral science
i'm also interested in artificial
intelligence and internet of things
so i've taken some classes at mit and i
am a microsoft mvp in
ai and i'm also part of
of the steering group for two meet up
syrian oslo
oslo ai and the norwegian.net user group
so what is web assembly
um so webassembly has its origin
in uh in 2015 so all the major web
browser uh vendors they gathered
together and they
did a draft of uh web assembly in the
end of 2017
and then they published it in february
of 2018.
and so the goal goal here for
webassembly is to have
like a binary format so that you can run
native code inside of your browser
so in this presentation we will both
have a look at
webassembly how you can write it and we
will also
have a small demo of how you can write
your own webassembly and then how you
can package it
package it with npm and then how you can
then download the mpm package and use it
in your own web application
first if we cons contrast javascript and
webassembly we can see that javascript
is more
of a high level language it's flexible
expressive
dynamic typed and you don't need to
compile and also it has a huge
ecosystem whereas web assembly is much
more low level
and it's we will see in a couple of
slides we will see what it looks like
but it looks like an assembly
like language it also has a compact
binary format
and one of the advantages with using
webassembly is that you can have near
native
performance so either you can write
webassembly
manually which i don't recommend or you
can use
a high level language like c or c plus
plus or rust
and go and then you can use a tool or a
compiler to compile down
your high level language to webassembly
so this is an illustration this is taken
from a blog series by lynn clark
so so you will get all of the references
at the end of the presentation
but basically what this illustrates is
that what usually happens is that you
have
a high level high level language like c
or c plus plus
and then you compile this high level
language
down to something you can call an
intermediate representation
and then you have a second part of the
compiler will actually compile it down
to the target architecture
which is then in this illustration can
either be an x86
architecture or an arm architecture
but now with web assembly it's a little
bit different because now here we have
code that we baxter
executed over the web so that means that
we don't really know which target
architecture will it run on finally
so a webassembly can be described as a
machine language for conceptual machine
and these webassembly instructions are
also called virtual instructions
so what will happen is that the brown
browser will download webassembly
and then it can compile down to the
target that it's running on
as i said before here so webassembly
which is abbreviated was
is a new browser standard it is based on
a previous
product called asm.js which you can read
up on
more and it's an intermediate language
in the same way as
java compiles down to bytecode and
c-sharp compiles to
msil it's a strongly typed language but
we only have four different types we
have
integer 32 integer 64
and float 32 and float 64.
if we take a look here at the hello
world program or hello watson program
since i just mentioned that we only have
four different types of
types in this language and and they were
integers and floats
it's quite it's a little bit complicated
to actually write a hello world program
so instead what is the equivalence of a
hello world programming in wasm
land is an either an addition or a
subtraction
or some more simple mathematical
operation
so we will make our own add this uh
hello world
program in in awesome
so um webassembly has a format which is
called
wat which stands for web assembly text
format
so this is how we can write uh our web
assembly code
so what we have here is we define a
function called add2
and we defined two input parameters
which is
integer 32 and then we also declared
that the
result from this operation should also
be an integer
32 and it's also stack based language so
here we
get local on the first memory position
and get local
second memory position and then we call
a function here
i32 add so there are some some 60
different types of functions that you
can use
in webassembly and then we also have to
declare what will this function actually
be called for
you know for the calling function so we
export it as
a function name that should be add two
and this
add two is an alias for the function
that is called
add two here in the w80 example
so we can use a tool here which is
called what to us
or webassembly text format to wasp so we
just run the second
command line based tool so we run what
was with our webassembly text format and
then we define what kind of
uh what kind of format we want to have
as an output and
in this case it's an object format or a
binary format so it will be
to the add.wasm and we can also have a
look
at what this looks like in what our
binary format will actually looks like
and then you can see here on on the
slide that
this looks uh very much like an assembly
language
but how do we do now if we want to use
our web assembly
that we have built so the first thing is
that we need to
touch the wason file and then we can
read it into an array buffer
and then after that we can use
webassembly since webassembly is
standard so it's is supported in all
major browsers we can call
webassembly.instantiate with this
bytes array that we just read in and
then from
the results of this we can take the
results.instance.export
and then here we declare the function
name that we
declared in um in our web assembly
called add2
so we assign this to a javascript object
at 2 and then
we can just run it as a regular
javascript object so we
has to see what it looks like just make
a lot and then add two of two
integers so then we will have
we have made our first hello world uh
program in
in awesome
so another tool which can be interesting
to have a look at is something called
the awesome code explorer
so uh so with some code explorer you can
load a binary wasm file
into the wasm code explorer and then you
can have a look at
the text format of that file so here we
have actually taken the
binary file that we downloaded and then
we've uploaded into the
wasm code explorer and then you can see
here on the right hand side in this tool
that we get the same texture
representation as
what we actually added in the first
first place
but this is quite the cumbersome to
write webassembly by hand so that's not
really recommended so instead what i
said was that what we would like to do
is we would like to use
a high level language like c or c plus
plus or rust
or go and then we would like to compile
this down
to web assembly so i'm going to show you
how we can do this
using rust
and before that before we do that we
have to have just a quick introduction
to what trust
is
so rust this um a system programming
language from mozilla
so it says a syntax similar to c or c
plus plus
it's strongly typed and it's compiled
down to native
code and one of the design goals with
rust as a language is that it should be
memory safe guarantee
and that's a that's a very huge benefit
with using rust
now when we use rust we need to be aware
of the tool chain here
so the tool chain basically consists of
three different tools
so first up is rust up that's an
installer for the
for us and then we have something called
cargo with which is the rust package
manager
so there is um there's a compilation of
different
uh crates so
you can see you can have a look at
crates that i o that this
sort of the package registry for the
rust community
and then we have rust c or rust compiler
so that's the compiler for
rust if we
make a hello world program here we can
define a function and it should
print out hello world and then we can
just
run raft compile with the main.rust and
then
on windows it will generate an exe file
and then it will just execute uh our
rust
code
you can also use cargo if we also in the
in the command line if we write cargo
new
and then the name of our name of a
product it will create a binary
application
and the project so you will get a source
the folder containing
rust file main rust file and you will
also have a package
declaration which is called tommel
so in our main rust file we have a
definition for a main function
and then it will just print out the
hello world
and then in the in the tumble file we
have the package definition where we
need to define the name of our package a
version name
and also the authors and if we have some
dependencies
on some other crates we can define that
also here in the
package definition we can use cargo to
run
uh to run this so we just run cargo run
then it will will come by compile our
product and then we'll also run the
exe file that will be generated and then
we can see the result of it
in our command line window
so with rust we also have some types
here so we have primitive
primitive types we have boolean integrin
float and text
we also have some primitive constructs
like tuples and arrays
function pointers and so on
so now when we know a little bit more
about trust now we'll
look at how can we use rust to generate
a web
assembly file and then publish it up to
npm
so first thing that we need to find out
is how can we
compile rust down to webassembly
so the first step in order to do that is
to install this rust tool chain that i
was just talking about
and then we need to add a new compiled
target which is called wasp32 unknown
unknown
so with that target then the uh
the rat compiler knows how to compile it
down to webassembly
and then we also need to install
something called the bind gen by
vosm so what's binding what it provides
for us is
that provides bindings from uh from the
application javascript code
to rust and to wasm so that you actually
can call your
uh your file from your javascript code
this is an example here so here we have
uh the package definition so we call it
the hell wasp
silver is the name of our package and we
defined some version and the
description and then we define what kind
of library is this so uh so then we have
something called the c
dynamic library which we put under a
crate type and then we also need to
find some dependencies so one of the
dependencies is this tool that i was
talking about
there was bind gen and what it actually
does is generate some glue file that we
will have
look at
this is our rust main failure
so we need to define that we have
dependency on an external crate
in this case it's the was buying gen and
then that we want to use also it was
binding and after that we can define an
external function an
external javascript function that we
want to use we want to
be able to use the javascript function a
lot in order to print out something here
and then we can define our function
which is
a public function that we that the
calling
application will be able to use so we
call
we name our function greet and it has a
string input parameters
and then we just use the standard alert
function in order to
print this out on the screen
so we then want to be able to package
this so that we can load this
up onto npm then we can run the command
here called was
pack init so what that will generate it
will generate
a package folder uh with this content
and then we can just publish it
yes thus we would publish any other
regular npm package we can just do the
npm publish
package and as you see here then the
result is that on npm we have
a package that that someone else can use
to in order to add it to their own
application
so we'll have a quick look here at what
has been generated
into our package folder so you can see
here that there are four different
files
the first file is a typescript file uh
so in this type of value it's declared
what this
the different types of functions that we
will be able to call from
javascript so here we can see that there
is a great
function that we will be able to call
and we can also see
what is the form at our input parameter
and what uh
what will the output be and then it also
generates
something that we can call a glue file
so that this hello was
silver.js so this is a javascript file
that you can call from you
with your own javascript application
code and this
uh this code this glue code will then
call into the web
assembly so you can see for example for
the function grid it will
try to pass a string down to wassum and
it will
take the input parameter that we that we
defined
and then it will try to call this return
wasn't
wheat which is the function that we
defined in the worst code
and then after that we have to free up
our memory
and then we also have the package.json
file and
that's just the regular package dot json
file where we define what
kind of files we have we have this uh
taptic trial and we also have this glue
file i was just
talking about
and this is then how we can use this in
our
web application so we can define a
webpack config
and we can define a package.json for our
web application and
in this package we just defined that we
have a dependency on our hello
silver package and then we can just
create a regular index file
and we point this we are using an
index.js file
where we can bootstrap our
wasam silver package we call
this asynchronously with jes and then
yeah sweet and then whatever you want to
have output
on the on the website
and then this is the result from
that this
has been sort of an introduction or a
simple example of how you can use
i can use rust in order to compile down
to
a web assembly and then how we can use
mpm to package this
web assembly and upload it to mpm
and then how we find out how we can use
the npm package in our own web
application
i'm going to show you a little bit more
complicated
application here where we have some more
input
so this is an application which is
an implementation of game of life
for for uh so for those of those of you
who
do not know game of life it's this
assimilation
so you have some rules for your
simulation that if you have live cell
with fewer than two live neighbors it
will die
because it's underpopulated or if you
have a live cell with two or three live
neighbors it will live on to the next
generation of our simulation or if you
have a
lifestyle with more than three live
neighbors it will die because then it
will be overpopulated and any dead cell
with exactly three live neighbors
will become a new lifestyle because of
reproduction
and you can have a look at this
example more on the link below or below
here
this is what it looks like
here we can see that the simulation has
started and then we can use
our post button
like this and then we can go in and edit
manually inside
our simulation so now we added some new
cells in the simulation and then we can
continue
running our simulation this is written
in web assembly and we're going to have
a look at how this
is done
again here is our package our cargo uh
package definition so we define the name
there was some game of life
and the author and the version and we
need to define what type of like
error is this so this is this see the
dynamic library
and then we also need to define our
dependencies so we need to
uh as before we need to have dependence
on this was
binding in order to generate this glue
code that i was
talking about
this is an extract of the actual rust
code that we're
using so here we define a sort of this
the game game plan or the universe so we
find the width and height and
was to define some accessor functions
for the width and height
and we also define a function here in
order to be able to toggle
or sell so
this is our typescript file where we
define what kind of functions
exist and what can be what can be called
from the outside world
so you can see here that we can call our
width and height and we can call the
number of cells
and we can also use call our toggle cell
function
this is this javascript glue file that i
was
talking about so again again here we
have example for the width it
tries to call the wasp.universe.width in
order to retrieve what is the width of
this
simulation plan and we also have the
toggle cell function which takes some
arguments in the x and y coordinates
for the cell that should be toggled and
it tries to cool down to the
wasp.universe
toggle cell function
then here in the html code we can just
define
a bootstrap javascript file where we can
load our
webassembly
and then we ask we can just import
this universe that we defined in our
package
for example over here we have just
highlighted that you can also call your
universe.toggle cell here from
your javascript file
so now some questions here about
performance because
because what i said in my introduction
was that
uh one of the benefits of using
webassembly is that you
will be able to run their native
performance
we're gonna have a quick comparison here
between if you run web assembly or if
you run javascript
in very common browsers in chrome and
firefox and in safari
so they have they've run the same type
of simulation
using both javascript and webassembly
and as you can see
webassembly is quite quite a lot um both
faster than the javascript but but what
maybe is even more important this
that it has a constant uh
spread so that if you run web assembly
you can be more certain of what type of
performance
you will will be able to achieve whereas
for example you can see
the middle one the javascript on firefox
has quite large spread of the different
uh trials so then you don't actually
really know what type of performance you
will actually get
in the end we should also take into
account that
webassembly is still quite a new uh
new language whereas javascript has been
with us for
a lot of times we have had much more
time in order to
optimize uh the javascript compiler and
the javascript runtime
so we we can expect that this
differences will be even more
will be even higher in the future
and i also have some examples here from
how webassembly has been used in real
world
applications
my first example here is for a digital
signal processing
library so uh one big benefit
of webassembly is is that you can
use if you have already a library which
is written
in any of these languages that i
mentioned like c or z plus plus
or go or rust and you want to vape
verify it so that you can use it over
the web
and webassembly is a great tool in order
to do that
here's an example of some people they
already had a c
library with some some transformations
for image transformations and video
video transforms
which is called web dsp and then i used
web assembly
in order to be able to run this on the
web
this is an example of what this looks
like so this is in real time where we
can
change or transform
video transform and then it just runs
through through webassembly and then
down to the
c code and
you can have this uh real-time
transformation
of your uh of your images and of your
videos so the best so the
so the benefit of this is that you
already have some application code that
you
are already using and that you you know
you can you can trust
and then it's a it's a small step to
just
use webassembly in order to be able to
call this
through the browser
another example of this is
uh is autocad so
for those of you who do not know autocad
is a company that deals with
drawings of constructions and buildings
and so on so
back in early so they have a huge
amount of drawings going back to both
the 70s and the 80s
that they still need to somehow be able
to provide to their customers
so um in 2010 they tried
the latest technology at that time which
was a flash app so
to do a viewer for autocad you were
using flash
and if we fast forward to 2014 then it
was
the html5 javascript was
was trending at that time so then they
made another
viewer application using that and then
in 2016
they used a compiler called
mscrypton to be able to compile c plus
plus
down to down to javascript
and then in 2017 they used something
called real dwg which is
their own uh format for the for these
drawings
they made a viewer for that which is
web-based
and then in 2018 they made an autocad
web app
web app using uh using web assembly
so the interesting thing with this is
how this uh how this application has
been
structured so basically you have on top
you have some uh some normal web
technologies like react and typescript
and then
you have ui you can have ui component
libraries and then you have this
webassembly
binary and this will call down to the
autocad core library which is this c
plus plus
code that means with instead of
having to rewrite their their whole
portfolio of uh
of code they could instead just use
webassembly and
reuse reuse their existing native c
plus libraries and expose this as a web
application
i'm going to be talking about some
future plans here for
web assembly one thing that i've
mentioned in my talk here is that we
have some javascript glue file
which acts like a sort of intermediary
between your application code and the
web assembly
so but that's not very performant so uh
so what they want would like to try to
do is would like us to be able to call
directly
to the dome or like directly to a web
api
and not having to
not having to be restricted to this glue
file that i was talking about
and then the same thing we would also
like to just be able to
do an import or was main javascript so
so as
as maybe you saw here in my previous
examples i
had to load my uh javascript a song
currently in order to be able to run it
but they would just
want to be able to import it just as any
other type of library
and then in addition they would like to
support more languages
so um so as of now
it's uh one of the criteria for
um language to able to compile compile
down to your
web assembly is that you can't have
a garbage collector so
so for example java is not supported as
of as now
another new thing here is called
serverless web assembly
so webassembly is not only for the
browser we have
some different providers like cloud fire
and fastly that can support
web assembly so that you can actually
write
serverless your service function in web
assembly
so why would you want to do that one of
the things is that you will have
much faster launch time and you don't
need to rewrite maybe you already have
some server
code then you can just use web ascend
web assembly instead of rewriting it to
your script
so this is an illustration of the
different types of options that we have
either we can have webassembly running
on the backend then we call
webassembly from the front end we can
have client-side javascript
or we can have client-side webassembly
or we can have this serverless web
assembly that i was just
talking about
also something called version website
system interface
so one of the ideas with this initiative
is that they want to be able to
run web assembly outside of the browser
so um to make it less restricted so that
you can actually run it in
different environments um but then we
need to have an interface for this
conceptual operator system that could
interoperate with this versi standard
and the goal for this is that you should
be able to be able to run represently on
all types
of operating systems so as of now
when you run web assembly in the browser
it needs to
adhere to the same type of safety
restrictions as javascript so there are
lots of things that you can't do with
webassembly but if you if
this versa standard comes into place
then you can have some sort of
intermediary that can
negotiate with the operating system and
see if
is this file okay okay to be run and if
it is it will just
transfer the file over to over to the
operating system
now finally i'm going to talk a little
bit about some
some other frameworks here for uh that
is using
uh webassembly
so one of this framework is called
assemblyscript
so assembly script compiles a subset of
typescript
down to webassembly using a compiler
called binarian
and you can see here an example of how
that
looks like and one of the things that
you need to be aware of if you
run assembly script is that you need to
handle the memory allocation so you
both need to allocate some memory before
you start
to use your uh yeah before you start use
your assembly script and then you also
need
to free your free your memory
when you're done using it
and we also have blazer i know there are
several
talks uh at this conference that talks
about laser so i'll just
mention this very very briefly basically
base basically laser is a framework that
where you can
write your web applications just using
regular c-sharp
so it has there are two types of flavors
of
blazer either you can run it on the
server and then you have clients
events that it sends back using signal
or or you can run it on web assembly
so then you will actually have a version
of the
net framework running on webassembly
one important question here is isn't
this just the new old new old new
haven't we you know haven't we just seen
all this before
we take some examples from the past we
had activex and we also had flash and we
had
silverlight and none none of these were
uh
has survived so why would why would the
um why would web assembly have a higher
chance of
success than these previous frameworks
and so for once all of these were
proprietary to
the company that was making this um
these toolkits whereas webassembly is
is a standard that has been agreed upon
between the different
browser vendors so there is a much
higher probability that this
will be something that we can make use
of a long time in the
in the future
so what is the conclusion of all of this
because when
uh as first started to hear about web
assembly
one of them one of the sort of the
headlines was that javascript is
instead and long live webassembly
so the question is here should we do
awesome all the things
i don't necessarily necessarily think
that i think that webassembly is just
one other tool in your toolbox and it's
one of one of the use cases where it
really shines is
if you already have a set library of
either c or c plus plus code
and you want to be able to expose this
out in the browser and you don't want to
rewrite your whole library then web
assembly is a really great
candidate for for that
but another thing that we also need to
be aware of is that we're
still sort of in an early phase so
there's a
there's a lot of tooling that can be
improved because
uh quite frankly some of these tools are
a little bit clunky to use right now and
it's not super
user friendly but i think that this will
also change
with time
so to finish my presentation i will also
give you some
some reservances with some articles
where you can read
up more on autumn webassembly and you
can also
read a little bit more about laser if
you're interested
into that with that i hope that you
find this inspiring and that you would
like to find out more about
webassembly and
you want to reach me you can reach me
either on twitter or you can send me an
email
and i will be here throughout this
remaining three days on the conference
so we both on the
prosec channel so if you have some uh
still have some time
left here for questions so you can write
your questions either in the q and a
panel here on webex or you can write
some questions
on slack with that i would like to thank
you all for your time
thank you so much